[Music]
hey what's up good folks this is john
with the dr john dolone
show on today's show we are talking
about mom guilt with special needs kids
we were talking about immature partners
and co-parenting and we were talking
about
a couple getting on the same page with
how they spend their money
stay tuned
hey what is up i'm john and welcome to
the dr
john dolone show this is a collar driven
show where we talk about your
relationships your life your weird
neighborhood your hoa
conspiracy theories your mental health
anything and everything your
marriage parenting all of it the world
has
lost its mind
man people are struggling with their
mental health divorce rates are
up people are out of work divided things
are just generally a mess
and good folks i am here to help i want
to walk alongside you and provide you
with wisdom
wisdom from emerging science and
research and ancient wisdom
and truths and insights that we have
forgotten
because we've gotten so big and so fast
and so arrogant and so impressed and
satisfied with ourselves
we can all feel that we've entered into
this new vortex like the world is
somehow different
and we don't fully have our heads around
it yet but there's no going back right
and so i'm here to walk alongside you
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291
this show is about you real people
real callers real advice from real
experiences
and real research let's do this if you
don't want to call
email me at askjohn ramseysolutions.com
and i will do my best to answer your
email on the air
so here's the deal why in the world
if you are a thinking person you are
asking yourself why in the world do we
need
another podcast every actor every
grandma every fortnight nerd down in his
basement
everybody's got a podcast right why do
we need another one by the way who even
are you deloney your name rhymes with
the lunch meat for crying out loud you
got no books out you co-host the dave
ramsey show every once in a while and
you think you're all fancy and you need
a podcast
so what are you doing what are we doing
here here's the thing for the past
two decades right almost 20 years
that sounds a long time right i've
walked alongside
countless people during some of their
most exciting
and some of their most dark moments
right some of the hardest moments of
their lives
lost loved ones funerals weddings new
jobs getting fired getting married
getting separated
all of it and along the way i've
wrestled with my own mental health
issues
my own marriage and relationship demons
i've earned two phds one in higher
education
and one in counseling and i've spoken
and studied with folks across the
country
from harvard to tiny little
you know faith-based schools in in south
texas
to k-12 programs all of it right and
i've partnered with families
parents business leaders from executives
down to hourly employees
everyone deserves to live lives of
dignity
joy and purpose and here's the thing
despite how crazy it is out there
how angry everybody is how fired up and
charged everything is
i'm an eternal optimist and i've seen it
over
and over again that there is happiness
meaning relationships and laughter on
the other side
of disconnection mental illness and hurt
and so that's why i'm committed to this
show
i'm committed to talking to you all the
time
talking to you taking your your emails
your instagram things
on the tubes your phone calls i want to
get out there and talk to real people
with real struggles and help folks turn
that corner to the next
right best thing and go find hope
connection enjoy so let's go straight to
the phones let's fire out on the phones
i don't even know what fire out means
like we're in some kind of
i don't know battle of some sort we're
not i'm just taking phone calls on a
radio show but let's go to cherry
in pensacola florida sherry how are you
i'm doing great dr john how are you i am
doing outstanding
how can i help this morning so i have a
two and a half year old daughter who has
some special needs and i worry that i am
failing her as a mother and that i'm not
doing a good enough job that is a lot so
tell me about your baby girl
she was diagnosed with hearing loss at
two months
okay and she she has developmental
delays all around so she didn't walk
until she was two
she doesn't talk yet we don't have any
other official diagnosis
but sometimes i just worry that maybe
i'm not a good enough
mom and that's why she's behind
so where does this idea of i'm not a
good enough mom come from
do you have some guilt over the
some of the physical challenges and the
developmental challenges
yeah i feel like i have a lot to go over
mostly the developmental i feel like i
was prepared for the speech because
she's got the hearing loss
um but then the other things that
started to follow that we don't know
where they're coming from yet i think
that's where the
guilt and the worry is starting to come
from
tell me what your support network is
like
well i just moved to pensacola two weeks
ago
my husband just got out of navy boot
camp
we joined us a little bit later in life
um but i have great support now
uh before when my husband was in boot
camp it was just me and her
while i was working from home all day so
it was hard
to try to do my job 40 hours a week
take care of her make sure i was doing
enough with her and she's also gonna
have a little sister
in december oh my gosh so you are in it
in it in it
sherry so you just moved your husband's
finishing
boot camp um luckily there's nothing
going on
globally that you know would be freak
out a spouse who loves her husband right
um you've got a child with special needs
and you've got another one on the way
so you are you are in the middle of it
right
yes definitely so here's a couple of
things i want to pass along to you um
i don't talk about this much in fact i
don't think i've ever talked about this
publicly even on the dave ramsey show
or in any of the social media stuff that
i've
i've done since joining this team um i
actually have
spent some significant time with
disability rights
associations working with students with
special needs working with their
families
over the last 15 17 18 years
um my best friend on planet earth my
oldest friend on planet earth
was in a tragic car wreck after he
graduated college
and has been a paraplegic ever since and
that started me down a road of
caring for folks who just are less
able-bodied or have different abilities
and have different forms of access and
support than
traditionally able-bodied people and so
i want to give you a couple of things
that i've learned in my experiences of
walking alongside parents
and then give you some things to think
about globally is that cool
yes it is all right so number one
this idea this feeling that you are
failing your kid
is not exclusive to a mom with special
needs
of a special needs kid every mom and
every dad on planet earth
with their first two-year-old looks in
the mirror and says
i'm doing this miserably and i'm my kid
should have had other parents i'm no
good at this
what am i doing right and if you're a
parent and you haven't had those
thoughts
then you i'm going to challenge you to
love your kid harder right
so i want to norm that feeling for you
number two
okay do you love your baby yes
how much more i would do anything for
her
more than anything in the world i can
hear that through this one
five minute phone call i can hear it
from you okay
i trust that you love your baby i know
that you love your baby
and if you will let that be first and
center
if you will hold that kid you will look
her in the eyes
you will hold her hands and her feet and
you will read to her
and you will go get in the dirt outside
with her
you will get her the support care that
she needs as her needs develop
hearing loss by the way can
is such a a bearing for young kids
and so it wouldn't surprise me as you
guys get a handle on hearing loss
over time the developmental delays may
catch up
right so if there's not other
comorbidities if there's not other
diagnosis that goes along with this
um a kid that can't hear um or is
hearing challenged early on
it just takes a minute for things to
catch up right um
and so i wouldn't cash in all your chips
at this point
here's the third thing you got to get a
community of people around you that's
going to walk alongside you and let you
be frustrated and let you be upset
and let you be angry and let you feel
guilty all those feelings are normal and
they're
good and they're nothing to beat
yourself up over but you do need other
folks in your life that will lift you up
when you're having those hard days and
those hard moments
when you move to a new town especially
and you join the military community
they have a really great way of wrapping
their arms around you really fast
but sometimes those can be transient and
shallow relationships
and so don't be afraid to dig into a
group of moms in pensacola
who are special needs moms or hearing
loss moms there are
communities everywhere whether they're
virtual or they're in real life
and of course i always default to
real-life relationships but that you can
plug into directly and get connected
with
and then here's the final thing you've
got another kid on the way
love and cherish the new kid that's
coming
the same as you love and cherish the the
baby that you have
and just let whatever chaos comes is
going to come
but you're going to love those babies as
much as you can right
how much how much fear do you have this
is gonna happen again
or that they're somehow your fault and
you're worried about baby number two
yeah i feel like there's definitely some
fear there as we get closer to her
due date right so what i want you to do
as best as you can and i know this
sounds so ridiculous because i've never
carried a baby i don't have
any idea what that emotional weight and
the psychological and spiritual way of
carrying a baby is
so i'm just telling you secondhand just
being an old a dad
enjoy every second that you possibly can
okay okay you are a great mom
you're gonna love your baby your kid's
gonna have challenges and if
let's just say heaven forbid um she ends
up being hearing challenge completely
and she's never able to hear the sound
of your sweet voice ever ever ever
she will be able to see you she will be
able to feel you
she'll be able to communicate with you
and she will continue to love you i
don't think that's going to be the case
my hope is that there's going to be some
solutions some technological solutions
some
some medical solutions to the hearing
loss and the development delays will
catch up and i'm going to continue to be
optimistic and positive about that
but at the end of the day that's
secondary to you mom
not letting your guilt override the fact
that
me and my husband created a baby with
hearing challenges or developmental
delays
that i'm not a good enough mom i'm not
plugged in enough
i've heard i hear that from regular moms
i also hear that from moms and dads
especially needs kids we don't know what
to do we feel paralyzed
we had this plan that was going to be a
b c and d and now the plan is
efg elementop qrs right whatever
letters get together in a row here
my promise is if you love that baby and
you are
not um hesitant to reach out for help
and support and you wrap around you wrap
yourself around a community
and let a community wrap yourself around
you man that baby's gonna have an
awesome awesome
time with you as her mom i'm excited for
i i've dealt with a lot of kids who
with had special learning needs and had
special mobility needs and had special
mental health challenges and their
parents didn't care their parents didn't
give two craps about them
or they were just annoyed by them or
frustrated to buy them and didn't want
to deal with it didn't want to
acknowledge the reality of it
and i could tell on the phone that's not
you so i am
i'm excited for this baby that that she
got you as a mom
and i'm excited um that your husband's
got you
as a partner willing to pack up and move
across the country while he
goes to support the military and i'm
grateful for you for your service
spouses don't often get the shout out
that they deserve but
call me back after your new baby is born
i can't wait to hear
how he or she is doing and i would love
to hear back from you when we get some
some more diagnosis down the road
on learning developmental delays and how
the hearing loss is going all that but
you are off on the right on the right
track you're a good mom
oh what a blessing what a blessing all
right let's go back to the phones let's
go to lauren in columbus
ohio lauren how are you hi dr john i'm
doing well thank you
outstanding how are you this morning
well i'm
okay i just have a quick concern
um i'm recently divorced and my ex and i
have a two-year-old son
i'm struggling with the example that my
ex sets
for him and i i don't do well with
keeping my opinions to myself
um still kind of have that spousal
i don't i don't either that's why we
started a radio show because i can't
keep my opinions to myself
so i just need help with that so you've
got a two-year-old is your two-year-old
split in time between the two of you
yeah equally equally so what are some
behaviors you're concerned with or what
are some examples you're concerned with
um there are two main ones my
my um he will not my ex won't let me
even step into his house when we do the
switch over
um just feels very protective of
um his space i guess um and my son can
see that
and then secondly if if my ex is dating
someone you know once or twice it
doesn't matter how many times um
or how many people he will introduce our
son to that
new person and that really bothers me
so does it bother you for your son or
does it bother you
that he's dating again
no that does not that doesn't matter to
me that he's dating someone
i just don't want my son to be
thinking that that's okay to you know i
don't want him to
to gain a relationship with somebody and
they're not going to be sticking around
perhaps yeah that's definitely
challenging have you sat down with your
ex and had that kind of conversation
yes uh and he says it's none of my
business
so i would strongly i'm smiling here um
not out of funny but smiling out of whoo
that gets me
gets my blood boiling a little bit so it
a hundred percent is your business
because that's your kid
uh it's a thousand percent your business
because that's your child
yeah it isn't your business he's right
on who he's dating
that's fair it's not your business on
who he chooses to
remarry or any of that kind of stuff
he's accurate there
but who is your child is in the presence
of it does matter
it is your business and that's
nonsensical to say it's not
now when it comes to what you can
actually do about it
not a lot not a lot and so
you mentioned that whenever you go to
drop off your two-year-old and you make
the pass there
um your husband doesn't want you coming
inside and the kid can feel that tension
there
um my recommendation would be to
not let that be a tense moment for your
son because right now he's going to pick
on
pick up the awkwardness between the two
of you if you don't feel awkward about
not going inside there's not going to be
awkwardness there
he will he won't get that tension does
it seem
silly probably um does it seem like
two people can't act like grown-ups that
are co-parenting
right that just seems weird right but
the kid's gonna pick up on the weirdness
not on the social cues because the kids
doesn't know that it's not impolite for
people not to come inside and drop off
car seats and
blankets and all that kind of stuff and
so is less awkward as you make it
um the better a couple of rules
that i like to er just thumbs i don't
say rules but a couple of
pieces of advice i'd give anybody
co-parenting
after a divorce especially if the other
person is a knucklehead or
is just acting like a child is
never forget that this is his dad and
as best as you possibly can
always speak positively about his dad
or as neutral as possible about dad
don't ever put a child in a position to
have to choose between one or the other
even if he talks about about you in the
future
hopefully he won't do that and i would
also
never quit trying to
have some sort of friendship or
co-parenting relationship with your
ex-husband and that may be hey can we
have a monthly check-in to see how
our kids doing can we have an every
couple of months can we go get lunch and
just talk about this is not a
relationship thing
this is just to deal with our kid
make sure we're on the same page with
doctors in schools and things like that
i've got several friends who co-parent
that way and it's extraordinary
and then i know folks who just want to
you know clap you know wipe their hands
of each other and pretend the other
person never happened
the the tragedy that is it did happen
you've got to be together y'all guys
have 16 more years of co-parenting
together
the best you all can do to get on the
same page early the better
um how long have you all been divorced
just since march
just since okay so this is relatively
new when did
he move out uh it was february
february okay so here's the thing my
guess is
the wounds are still pretty raw here and
there's still some
asserting of independence and i don't
have to do what you say and i'm this and
i'm that
some of that may be happening right now
um
and so maybe let some of that smoke die
down it's august so maybe
october or november revisit it or shoot
an email and says hey can we
circle up it's been six months um can we
have a meeting for the kid
um just to make sure we're on the same
page um and maybe he'll be open to that
maybe he won't
but i would recommend um doing the best
you can
to to continue to try to be a good
adult right and i said earlier said try
to be friends
that might be pie in the sky for now
hopefully down the road y'all can become
friends again and just
figure this thing out and be good
parents all for
your two-year-old child um
yeah that just gets so hard and guys
and men and women if you get divorced
and you have kids please
for the sake of your children put down
the pettiness put down the
is my house my rules put all that
nonsense down
just don't that immaturity
that lack of wisdom that lack of not
caring about the person
that your kid or kids are going to
become is so
dumb i wish there was some other fancy
word it's just stupid
it's dumb it's acting like a kid it's
acting like a child
be a grown-up if you're gonna get
divorced and you have kids
you will have to be in contact with that
other person
you will you're gonna have to so go to
breakfast once a month
email each other kindly whatever you
need to do to communicate
but be on the same page about how you're
raising your kid
go to the same doctor go to the same
schools
have somewhat the same values as
possible and i know you're going to send
me all your cards and
and youtube comments or whatever about
last time we wouldn't got divorced so we
could communicate that well
you're probably right you're probably
right but now that you're not you've got
to communicate that well right
um these are these are your kids they're
just more important than your petty
little nonsensical
i want my way i don't care about your
way care about your kids
care about your kids all right lauren
god bless you man i know that sucks and
that's hard
and i am hoping that your husband or
your ex-husband will
just think you know what maybe i
shouldn't be an idiot maybe i should
care about my kid
and i want my kid to um grow up to be a
functioning adult in society which means
me
and my ex-wife are gonna have to do this
together
all right let's go back to the phones
let's go to mary in washington mary how
are you
i'm doing okay thank you for taking my
call you bet thanks for calling in how
can i help
well okay so uh my husband and i
are at it in disagreement about um
paying for college for our youngest
child
okay um we finally got past
um while we're on the ramsey steps so
baby step two paying off a mountain of
debt
and now we've got baby step three and
four done so
saving for retirement have uh
congratulations
right way to go mary okay uh it's been
a long long haul okay so our youngest
daughter is in college
and my husband is pretty resistant to
helping her with college tuition
and i am fully on board with helping her
now he says
he doesn't like seeing the money get
spent i don't want her getting trapped
in debt like we have been
okay um we weren't able to help our
first two kids as much because we were
trapped in debt
um the my daughter is beginning her
junior year studying mechanical
engineering
she has a pretty decent portion paid by
an academic scholarship
okay and she's also holding down a job
um
she maintains a 3.5 gpa or above she's
in the honors college honors program
on the dean's list and such she does do
some typical college stuff
so her dad listens to her stories about
college life as if he's the cool dad
and then says to me he doesn't want to
fund that kind of college life
so oh yeah i disagree with his tactic
right i'm i'm angry at him and i don't
know how to resolve this problem because
he's
you know we had this giant mountain of
debt finally have some money that we get
to spend
and that's what i want to spend money on
and the mountain of debt
okay so i've let go of the anger and
resentment that was going on with
where the debt came from and how it was
accumulated and stuff that was going to
be my question is
is the debt him related yeah
i mean he he was he didn't do it on
purpose but he got kind of caught up it
was business debt okay
and he got sucked into the hole that a
lot of people are like well you financed
everything
and i found out about it because i was
working my own job
and raising kids and stuff and then i
you know looked over his stuff and said
what what is happening here
and so got him on track
but it took seven years to pay off that
much debt wow okay so
debt for a long time and now
we have no debt and we get to keep our
income
and move ahead but i want to help this
kid with college i didn't get to help
the other two with college well our
second
kid we helped a little bit because we
were getting closer to the end of the
debt
but he's resistant to this now i should
tell you also he's from a family that
higher education is not
important to them sure i mean when he
was
graduating from high school you know he
still had the cap and gown on and his
parents were like
are you giving back the keys are we
having the locks changed
you know right so he's not from a family
that
really values higher education i mean
they admire it but they don't
help their kids sure so let me hop in
here i
the question about paying for college is
a symptom of a deeper rooted
issue here issue number one is
you haven't let go you being you mary
you haven't let go of that seven year
journey you all took
there is still a part of you that has
resentment
has hurt has frustration has anger has
whatever words you want to put there
has a rage that you spent seven years
digging out of a hole that you didn't
that you didn't dig and until you
let that go and until my guess is your
husband
either has some sort of um
guilt that he carries around that he dug
a hole like that whether it was on
purpose or stupid
or he's annoyed that you're frustrated
whatever that is
right but here's here's here's why
you've gotta put that stuff down
because you two can't fully dream
together on what tomorrow's gonna look
like if you're still carrying bricks
from the past
and what you're telling me about your
daughter there's gonna be guilt from
your husband that he didn't help the
first two
or didn't help the first one and only
help the second one a little bit and so
he probably should help the third one
or the third one gets to go out and
party and drink beer and that means
by default i'm not finding that kind of
life because i got to work hard and i
and you know i get that that attitude i
hear i hear that often as well
um so there's both you're going to have
guilt that you didn't help so now you
got a chance to we could
could be helping both those of the
guilts both of these should we or
shouldn't we
that's simply a values question and you
can't have values conversations if
you're still hanging on to the past
and so my deepest deepest
recommendation for you is to spend some
time with yourself
spend some time with a pastor or
counselor
or you may have already done this mary
you may have already done this hard work
but
go spend some time with your husband and
you all go get breakfast somewhere
my friend anthony o'neil he always says
go to a nice dinner i like doing a nice
breakfast because everybody's fresher
and a little bit smarter in the morning
and a little bit more bright eyed and
coffee helps a little bit
but go have a breakfast off-site go
somewhere
where y'all can get out and if you're in
washington washington still may be
closed down so
go hiking together go somewhere and
i want you to write him a letter
that goes through with the last seven
years with the 10 years were
paying for this debt and you apologize
for holding this on
for so long and i want you to look in
the eye and say i'm letting this go
i forgive you i forgive us i'm proud of
the journey here we
are moving forward and then number two
is
i want you to say i want to have a
values conversation about what the back
half of our life is going to be or the
last
25 of our life is going to be how are we
going to actually spend this money
because for your husband it may feel
so good that he finally has some in the
account and any of it leaving
hurts right because he just doesn't want
to go back to that place
and for you finally having something to
count god almighty dude we just want to
help out people we're going to
and we want to help by we're gonna start
helping by looking at our own
daughter and helping her out she's doing
great she's kicking butt
she's gonna go be a successful member of
a family of a community
she's making us proud and i'm gonna
support that that starts with a values
conversation
my friend chris hogan calls it planning
in hd
i like to say plan it with a picture i
want you to
draw a picture of what thanksgiving is
going to look like in five years and
work
back draw a picture about christmas
morning
in five years who's around the tree what
gifts are you handing to people
and work backwards from that
when you what's a picture of your
daughter crossing the graduation
stage does she have a diploma in one
hand and student loan dead in the other
does she have a diploma in one hand and
she is waving to you guys
up in the stands hopefully we're not
still doing virtual graduations then
but she's waving to you with a debt-free
hand what does that picture look like
and when you paint in pictures with
partners
it's just so much easier to see it and
you feel it
it's not this abstract thing not this i
don't want my kit
it becomes look hon i want my daughter
to walk across that stage
free i want her to be free of this
nonsense
and right now we can help but that comes
first
with you letting go too so mary thank
you so
so much for that call um
anybody who's struggling to get on the
same page with your partner you've got
to first look in the mirror
about anything what kind of car we
should have should we get on the dave
ramsey financial plan
should we have another kid should we
help pay for college
should our kids be wearing those clothes
out in the community my kids got a crazy
mohawk right now
and my wife was like do we have to let
him go out into the neighborhood looking
like that right
those are all values conversations and
you can't have values conversations when
you're frustrated you can't have them
when you're angry and you especially
can't have
values conversations when you're hanging
on to things that have happened in the
past
so do the hard work if you can do it by
yourself great if you can do it in
community great if you need a
professional grade to
set down your bricks set down the crap
you're carrying about other people
get offsite get out of the emotion get
out of the crazy
and then have values conversations that
are looking to the future
not to the past and those often start
those often start with an apology right
i'm sorry for what i've held on to
and so let's go to let's transition as
we wrap the show up
let's go to the lyrics of the day one of
the greatest songs
ever written by one of the greatest
bands
in the history of music right in the
history of music and i know you
i love the beatles i love public enemy
public enemy's good the beatles are not
right but some of you
are saying there are some better bands
than this and here's the thing you're
wrong you're wrong
depeche mode is one of the greatest
bands ever ever and their classic hit
i think it was from the 80s policy of
truth
goes something like this things could be
so different now it used to be so
civilized you will always wonder how it
could
have been if you'd only lied it's too
late to change events
it's time to face the consequence for
delivering the proof
in the policy of truth never again is
what you swore
the time before never again is what you
swore
the time before
never again my friend and mentor dave
ramsey's always talking about never
again moments
i used to be so civilized
never again never again am i going to
carry bricks of nonsense never again am
i going to carry
guilt i'm going to feel it i'm going to
put it down and then i'm going to go
be about making a better tomorrow for me
the people i love in my neighborhood
this
is the dr john deloney show
[Music]
you